how's it going bros my name is mark
[Music]
leave your entries in us already closed
episode why
welcome to the way last week you I are
look why the show where you guys think
you make fun of me but I make fun of you
because I get all that revenue damn it
alright let's see what kind of memes you
guys posted this week oh I'm sure
they're gonna be so nice what do we got
new meme new meme new meme meme review
stop singing did I kill memes I made me
was better bonus meme gets hit on the
far side of the screen
the real reason there was no bonus means
ah yes the two genders hoes and man ah
yes the intellectual expression of the
genders
speaking of Daisy from Star Wars that
reminds me of the good old means that
represents people of all genders to
genders all races and
cards I made a portrait painting of
Pierce I hope you like it I know I'm
supposed to be thankful and I'm known
supposed to be happy but it's my nose
really that big thank you very much
press f to pay respect he bored cat oh
he brought kicked I thought it was just
a puppet this whole time he had the hand
up in the puppet and then that's how he
played how is it possible
oh my god bento actually play the
keyboard what
that's incredible bento ah no bento
universals picture source of income
movies and own content beauty pies
videos that's right basically for those
who don't know my last meme review
video got demonetised by oats back
that's right my revenue my money good
justice has been restored when you're
not invited to youtube rewind when
you're not invited to howtobasic phase
reveal that's correct I wasn't invited
the head said yes that's what happened I
am NOT howtobasic
up vote if you can hear this image stop
we need to let this meme go you can have
the chair meme but this meme has to go
you go to youtube gaming and it's
literally all for tonight it's all for
tonight it's all for tonight it's all
for tonight everyone is playing for at
night goddamn I was banned from every
gaming Royale game of all time because
of this meme so let it go when Marcia is
in a pity pie video a surprise to be
sure but a welcome one man the prequel
means have to be the best group Amin's
coming out of one source of
entertainment I feel like it deserves
its own video probably will do it later
this week
dear mom gay
[Music]
why is the FBI meme still clinging about
all the means that I rate the lowest are
the ones that keep going except the
chair forgets the handshakes awkward
hugs is where it's at
who took this Oh duck face and why do
you hug it's like can I have a hug
yeah sure here there you go are you
happy are you happy these clothes look
exactly like my dealers thank you thank
you so much
oh that's great I'm gonna steal that
right away
good mean good mean bravo a picture of
pewdiepie made of pictures of markiplier
are they crying markiplier ones I don't
think so too bad try again next time I
want the crying PewDiePie out of crying
market pliers and then I'll be impressed
stop wasting my time will pewdiepie ever
died translated into Greek and then
translated Greek into English
the PewDiePie will never die if there's
ever been more solid evidence to the
fact that I have never died let this be
it when you find me dead you will find
me not dead I'm sure during its catch
you can't kill what is already dead
upvotes of peers can give answers ok so
basically what happened was I was yeah
my dog get in there's nothing you here
for this stop stupid bird which one
should I pick as my wife too bad Natsuki
is trash I'm sorry my dear I'm going
with Monika new Levi's video an accurate
amount of people watching bonus me oh
you know I film the bonus meme every
time no matter what Jers know that think
of all the lost means
let's have a moment of appreciation for
that all the lost memes that would never
see the light of day posted this life
sweet got a ton of support for dinner
Megan - Lola why people were saying this
should be Felix new avi for YouTube so
I'm posting it again that's really cool
I would love to use it but it looks way
too professional for anything to be
associated with me okay here on the feet
of pi Channel we're stuck with mediocre
agency if it gets above that then you
know something's up okay you know
something is wrong so thank you but no
thank you
when you see how big his mousepad is
that's right how do you think I gotta
get a girl like Marcia what the heck is
this picture it's absolutely terrifying
what's wrong I'm scared I'm scared of
going home now am i dating I'm a
reptilian monster thisis three means
with no boners means - means with what
that's what it's very different for the
average view or maybe you haven't been
on the channel long enough to really
graph the idea behind the bonus meme but
it's a it's a very much different thing
that's right she'll keep seeing this
felix side
I wonder what's it going to save
give this ship its food
get me he got memed everybody
you guys are creative sometimes of
course not always upload this so I can
see the horror in pewds face its 369
that's a great price and you can do 69
on it
look it's super easy you're welcome we
are dropping the price it's 369 it's 369
369 this is our joint when you're a
successful fashion designer
businesswoman and a huge youtube
personality having 7.21 million
subscribers but everyone on our peopie
submission treats you like an innocent
ten-year-old girl awoke Marcy I mean
seal of approval well done whoever did
this I couldn't agree more of course oh
[Laughter]
my god so cute she just looks just like
Matt Sookie if only they'd switch the
shirt and the skirt my god so kawaii
destiny to bad Natsuki is the worst girl
I'm sorry might see ya you're despicable
and this makes me like you even less I
love you I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'm
Fridays with Peter pie dr. strange
oh we're using made-up names alright
yeah this is sad Fridays we beautify by
the way I forgot to tell you how's it
going bros welcome to fridays with
pewdiepie it's definitely different from
the wife complains about flexing on
YouTube
meanwhile I'll come on I can show off my
ride I was proud of that thing it's got
Korean wheels and a double clutch engine
you can't hate on me for flexing a
little bit come on guys I loved when I
did that video everyone gets so salty
like everyone just went into defense
mode no no I don't flex what are you
talking about hey I told you you guys
are honestly the most awesome
overwhelmingly supportive my favorite
group of people I am so lucky to have
you okay so it reads you mom gay haha so
clever am i right
never stop hudes optimism is great ah
such a sweet post read the first letter
of each line fan maybe you should read
the first letter of mine
no you it's time to end
now why YouTube favorite show thank you
guys for watching and supporting and
posting the memes keep posting the memes
in the subreddit it's right there have a
good fun
and be immortalized on the pita pies
subreddit think about it now too long
since this is fridays with pewdiepie
guys I love you so much I do not have a
twisted opinion about what some people
on the Internet sees me ass and just
overly emphasize the fact that there's
some sort of love connection going on
here even though I probably will never
meet you but I do love you very much
I love you guys so much you're my soul
you're my entity you're my being if I
ever meet you I won't shake your hand
but I will awkwardly hug you food for
thought and as always
[Music]
now drop it stop it never stop gonna be
the city and I've never gotta fly
tell me when I go I'm like whenever I'm
done with this Pastor Mike the Edgar